so would you call yourself the Bernie
Sanders I've been called worse
how y'all doing I'm running for mayor of
San Francisco running for mayor good for
mayor of San Francisco running for mayor
of San Francisco running for mayor here
we go oh there's a lot of plans first of
all we need to get human poop off the
streets you ready dignified places for
people who live on the streets because
about them we also need to tackle
homelessness I think we need to do is
tackle corruption just happen in San
Francisco at City Hall and make it more
affordable housing
yeah laughing in the paper huh yeah
I'm sick and tired of poor people in
this country we have so much wealth and
every we shouldn't have four people yeah
but some like ten thousand homeless
people on the street services go we have
probably more than ten thousand
millionaires it's a joke that you have
so much poverty young traitors are being
pushed out of places all over the
country DC New York San Francisco and
that's creating other centers of
creativity but just because it's
happening doesn't mean you shouldn't
fight against it you know just because
something's terrible is having to go
fuck it that's happening no no you have
to stand up for what you believe in if
everybody's donated you said they're
running tonight we'd have an extra
$3,000 don't know illusional we know him
winning is incredibly unlikely the
intent of this is to have a voice to
ensure that the issues that other people
are interested in get raised and that Ed
Lee has to respond to them unopposed
campaigns that's just not how the
democratic process is supposed to work
the goal of the campaign is to get Ali
out of office and if anything you know
if you don't agree with us if you think
we're crazy if you think that we don't
know what we're doing run against us or
join us but either way I'm saying that
it's okay for someone in the office to
be corrupt and that that's just how it
is is not okay think about it Lee is
like I respect the work he did thirty
years ago and he was pretty radical he's
gonna good do but then he just got
caught up in the system he just got
fucking sucked into it all and
I don't give a shit honestly if I get
30% of the vote
that's a fucking gangster ass move right
there I get 40% of the vote they're
gonna study me in history forever
do you think you stand a chance
anything's possible it's not likely but
that's not why I'm doing it I'm gonna to
make some fucking noise and to get
people to pay attention and giving me
the care and the memory and having room
200 we're in San Francisco home to the
on-demand economy
you